[Music]
hi
i'm curator emily allred and i want to
welcome you all to drawing games
chess posters from around the world one
of our summer exhibitions here at the
world chess hall of fame
this exhibition has over 100 chess
posters on a variety of subjects
mostly drawn from the collection of the
world chess hall of fame
and they're from over 100 countries this
exhibition
is really unique like really uniquely
encapsulates
our mission here at the world chess hall
of fame which is not just to
talk about the history of the game of
chess but also the art and culture of it
and so if you'll join me as we kind of
walk around the gallery you'll get to
see
a little bit of chess culture from
around the world
so we'll start over here which is a wall
of
posters about the chess olympiads and
as many of you know the chess olympiads
are team competitions
in which people from around the world
represent their home countries and this
year they did it virtually
but many years or most years it's
on different sites around the world and
so these
posters kind of uniquely represent local
cultures
you'll see this one which is from a
chess olympiad in the philippines
and it has the national bird of the
country
in the poster carrying a king piece in
front of the philippine
flag there are others where
they talk about kind of the mythology of
the country
or even have local landmarks like this
giant
camel bearing a rook on its back which
is an actual sculpture in dubai that was
created for
the chest olympiad there but still
stands today
we'll go ahead and take a look at some
of these other chest posters
which are from the most important chess
competitions around the world
the world chess championships so this
pair
of um of posters take two
very different kind of approaches to
representing the most important
competition in the chess world so
one distills the stakes of the the
competition
to a crown representing you know the
king of the chess world
the highest honors while the other
represents the drama
of the 1972 world chess championship in
which
um kind of this american
brash player is challenging boris baskey
who represented the soviet union and
they had dominated the chess world
since the end of world war ii and here
bobby is carrying his sack of cash he's
dressed as a cowboy on a night
and he's trying to snatch the crown from
boris baskey and the crown
has hammer and sickles probably
representing that soviet dominance of
the crown
and there are other figures you know
peering around
watching him and it just kind of
uniquely portrays that drama you know we
have the sister organization the st
louis chess club across the street so
big chess tournaments
are happening you know usually every
year and so we're kind of capturing
chess history here as it's happening
in st louis and these posters
represent that these are posters from
competitions held here on the st louis
chess campus
we have the 2019 junior chess
championship
we have the women's chess championship
and then
the karen's cup which was the last big
tournament we had here on campus this
year before
kovid 19 restrictions went into place
and these are all signed by the
competitors
and so you know we sell these in queue
boutique as well but it's kind of nice
to have these in our collection
as mementos of these really important
events
we also have a poster that we recreate
every year
for the new hall of fame inductions and
it portrays
each of the new inductees to the world
in the us chess halls of fame
thank you all for attending our virtual
tour of drawn games
chess posters from around the world i
hope that we'll get to see you here in
st
louis at the world chess hall of fame
sometime in the future
you